[Musique]
tu viens
allez tous me
[Musique]
manille ap hm must have a chanté par à
chanter c'est mon papa chamanistes pas
changé
les bouddhas j'ai tenu
moi aussi papa
[Musique]
oh oh non je me lève déjà tellement tôt
vous êtes bien sur la messagerie 2h
achats c'est moi je passerai te prendre
un quart d'heure plus tôt que prévu je
te revoir le dossier avant la réunion
avec winchester rappelle moi
[Musique]
c'est pas lui qu'on mangera au petit
déjeuner là c'est moi c'est joli ça m'a
fait bien moins chère mademoiselle rémy
c'est pas bien peindre il a dessiné
essentielle tout vert mais l'hiver quand
le soleil se couche sur le lac jamais vu
le ciel de venir vers argenté non jamais
et bien c'est dommage parce que c'est
une des plus belles choses qu'on puisse
voir
n'est ce pas rémi aux achats l'or mais
enfin tu es où
le fait qu'il soit souvent en procès on
ferait pour nous d'excellents clients
j'en suis convaincu tout va bien ça ne
fait pas plus de dix minutes qu'ils ont
commencé je vous ai mis les
contre-allées dire les profils et vos
notes bien entendu rupture génère en
outre d'énormes revenus
ben validé sur votre recommandation mais
renseignez vous bien sûr excusez-moi
j'ai dû passer prendre h
déjà là maintenant que nous sommes tous
là on peut commencer
c'est bon petit déjeuner
[Musique]
e
la classe quoi
dans l'ue de jouer dans vie dure et va
chercher à ciaccio
[Musique]
je peux vous le dire exactement
page 18 paragraphe 42 des wii
conformément à la garantie l'acheteur
remettra à la garde d'un tiers je vais
vous rappeler m j'étais attendu pendant
cinq minutes
j'ai pris un taxi de bono la gti nandy
de sms j'avais oublié mon téléphone ici
si tu étais venu vivre avec moi comme je
te les demandes et tu le sors c'est pas
le moment
dès que tu es parti winchester n'a fait
qu'une bouchée de mou normal belle à
croquer faut pas te laisser faire
c'était pas le prédateur été la proie
d'un ton cas c'est facile à dire il
vient de nommer associés pour me
reviendra faut pas m'en vouloir je n'ai
pas oublié ta robe je t'avais demandé la
ferte mais je te préfère danser là tu
veux tu essaies marsouins
puisque tu l'aiment tellement tu n'as
qu'à la porte et toi même ce soir
winnie allez-y doucement avec mon ami ce
soir 19h compter sur moi
teasdale c'est vous qui serait en
première ligne pour la fusion j'aurais
préféré un associé mais c'est vous qui
avez les meilleures relations avec
textile internationale ce sera un
honneur monsieur familiarisez vous avec
leurs ratios échange d'actions et leur
contrat de salariés midi dans mon bureau
déjeuner de travail comptez sur moi
encore merci jean
ap tirer mobilier tout ça
il ya marqué appelez moi je fais
c'est sans sucre oui bien sûr j'ai une
chose à tort
ce chien n'a ''jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
[Musique]
m teasdale non j'ai pas le temps je dois
être dans le bureau de winchester dans
deux minutes c'est votre soeur elle dit
que c'est urgent il y là j'ai pas le
temps de te parler tu me prends en plein
milieu du coi
c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
j'y vais pas ça c'est ton père je marche
sur des oeufs avec une gestion n'occupe
c'était un menteur que maman voyait
comme un cadeau du ciel
ça ça
il faut que tu y retournes à condition
d'avoir à mes côtés
sans toi je pourrai pas les affronter
non on ne peut pas s'absenter en même
temps tous les deux textile
internationale va devoir se contenter de
moi ça ma demande en mariage tient
toujours
tu peux me repousse et autres petits
bouts bas je m'accroche
appelle-moi d'accord
tél
[Musique]
j'aurais sauté je m'octroie
avec
it à winchester que j'ai apporté le
dossier avec moi que je peux très
facilement travailler d'ici et que je
suis au taquet avec jean jean
ça marche toujours avec deux boîtes de
conserve et la ficelle ici papa
[Musique]
mademoiselle mademoiselle mademoiselle
je suis dans la direction du monument
dédié à booker t washington
oh je n'en sais rien je ne dis pas ici
désolé cette année coûte petit me
rendais sur les crédits aux 880 wsl qu'à
votre radio locale à smith man telbec la
société de recherche sur ce midi le
monstre du lac nous a informés qu'il
avait été aperçue une nouvelle fois
rester avec nous dit tout sans trop
mignon
[Musique]
les
sarah est quand même venu didon
commenter ce biais c'est gentili merci
toi aussi
d'un autre côté tu aimes bien les vaches
oui alors toi tu aimes bien les garçons
qu'est ce que tu as fait ton frimeur
d'avocats ou fait il avait du travail a
en gros c'est un abruti
on croit entendre papa et ouais suis moi
[Musique]
à
avant
il dort un ami du temps j'atterris à
greensboro et de lacets 2h30
j'aurais tenté mais tu viennes les
touches des invités titouan gagner
gagner le jeu cruel auquel tu joues avec
ton père comme ça tu as réussi à ne plus
le revoir
maman elle ne le pense pas c'est pour
elle il ne pouvait pas deviner que j'en
aurai besoin besoin de quoi maman
j'éjecté de la cabane on tour la pelouse
de la halle il faut bien que quelqu'un
le fasse qui n'a qu'à engager un
jardinier des pollueurs ce banquier lui
il serait peut-être où trouver cette clé
où sont les papiers je ne suis pas votre
père ranger ses papiers
quel papier son passeport ces placements
s'arrache y laisse lui du temps c'est
mon domaine je te signal j'ai fait des
études de droit et hull est plus revenu
à la maison
lily il nous faut à manger pour la
réception oui j'ai recommandé chez
thinel non je peux y aller de toute
façon je dois est passé maman non savage
nom prend j'étais déjà payé un billet
d'avion une voiture de location
et dieu seul sait quand on te reverra
j'ai aussi besoin de ketchup j'aurais
pas devenir alors pourquoi tu es venu tu
me l'aurait jamais pardonné elle refuse
de l'admettre mais elle et j'ai obligé
de répondre désolé alors oui j'écoute
vous avez envoyé les contrats bien sûr
jean soyez gentils avancer mon retour
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
vous êtes marié mon petit nom vous avez
un petit ami oui c'est bête
j'aime tes fils qui a 26 ans et qui
serait parfait pour vous je peux compter
sur ses plateaux demain matin la
première robe rouge et comprises
s'éclairera puis tenez on l a noté donne
hélas la cus désolé je comprends que
vous ayez beaucoup pas faire seulement
c'est pour les obsèques de mon père il
est mort dans l'explosion aurait été
votre papa alors c'est terrible si je
peux vous aider en quoi que ce soit je
m'appelle vic n'hésitez surtout pas un
peu molle dit merci fiq du ketchup
c'est le 22ème manger vous n'auriez pas
de boisson énergisante sans sucre s'il
vous plaît murger quoi peut-être au
rayon ou ben stiller vous désirez team
mais affiche pour le festival du vin n
7o mais bonjour jeune fille
j mc à rennes je suis le président du
comité du festival du vin est candidat à
ma réélection l'an prochain je n'habite
pas là je vois alors tu loupes la
réunion via vic et pourquoi tu
m'appelles vieux vic
pourquoi ses plus grands week parce que
tu es vieux avec les plateaux ça vous
fera 46 74 46 74 donc matane et moi
juste 40 ça suffira oh non c'est parce
que je voulais dire à elle est là-bas ce
serait au minimum 200 à los angeles
il suffit d'aller chez brangelina et
leurs empreintes taylor kitsch up
attendait sara teasdale mes condoléances
ma grande
merci à désolé on s'embrasse chez nous
ne vous en faites pas pour les plateaux
oh non je peux pas accepter si si si
votre père était déjà un bon client
avant que vous marchiez et c'était un
ami dites à votre maman ya lille uc on
pense bien à elle je le ferai merci mon
dieu la porte
[Musique]
à tort
ces zones
[Musique]
non
un plan sans repas était du luxe ray
[Musique]
m
je
non
oh
[Musique]
m
je le savais
[Musique]
rupture immobilier
nous jurons solennellement de prouver
l'existence de ce mythique la très
vieille créature du lac de smith
mountain le diront
désolé pour le retard sa lucarne salut
tout le monde est prêt je on commence
d'accord d'accord
la société de recherche sur ce mythe y
entrant session premier point à l'ordre
du jour une minute de silence pour ré
a propos je suis tombé sur sa fiche est
inerte
j'aimerais bien épouser un non non non
pas lily l'autre l'avocate de los
angeles
quel autre bon passons deuxième point à
traiter les leçons à tirer de notre
dernière sortie
larry plus de dix nouveaux chocolats vu
qu'elle a fondu dans mon sac à dos bien
autre chose
nous disposons maintenant de jumelles à
vision nocturne avec ça il pourra plus
cacher le monstre ouais c'est le béton
larry je voudrais que tu es chagra bon
alors on est venus mois
[Musique]
on
vous avez vu l'émission de fauteur
manière son manga et ben j'ai pensé à un
truc on devrait faire venir ici
lorsque thurman viendra jamais à suivre
pendant l'année une ceinture skt tout
prestigieux oui comme son émission sur
le bigfoot de malaisie non non bob c'est
idiot les big foot existe pas ben je
sais très bien qu'ils existent pas karl
je crois que c'est un bigfoot qui a tué
kennedy h h ome rock of ages arrive
quasiment attendre comment ça se passe
c'est encore plus stressant que je
l'avais imaginé j'aimerais tant que tu
sois là h&h haut c'est trop trouva
qu'est ce qu'on voit qu'est ce que c'est
on dirait que c'est sarah à la recherche
de ce midi au lit
qu'est ce que vous faites salut tyler
s'est seulement nous la société de
recherche sur ce mythe y ont fait une
surveillance
en tout cas vous risquez pas de le voir
là haut l'eau c'est par là je vous
rappelle à laisser les riches et ouais
on s'en souvenait merci merci de
protéger et servir
bonsoir les gars là bas c'est sa coupe
ça arrête de nous torturer sers-toi de
la ligne fixe non parce que la note sera
astronomique et tu me laisserai pas trop
bourse et seigneur béni la nourriture
que nous allons consommer merci de nous
avoir ramené sahara je t'en prie
occupe-toi pile intérêts amen tu sors
toujours avec un jeune homme h oui je
fais quoi trois ans maintenant
depuis que j'ai fini mon droit et il n'a
pas encore fait sa demande en fait si
deux fois c'est pas sérieux s'il ne
vient même pas aux obsèques de ton père
c'est franchement pas des manières
on pourrait pas changer de sujet s'il te
plait ça va le boulou très bien
tellement bien que notre plus gros
client m'adore ils m'ont demandé de
négocier une énorme fusion ce qui
devrait booster ma promotion c'est vrai
que toujours été ambitieuse sahara
proche ou un compliment une constatation
plus ambitieuse c'est bientôt qui nous a
toujours poussé à nous ouvrir au monde
et à faire quelque chose de notre vie au
lieu de rester à attendre à marie
toujours partie en train de faire dieu
sait quoi
qu'est ce que tu cherches la seule chose
que je sois venu dire je sais qu'elle ne
peut pas l'entente u est avocate tu
devrais réfléchir à la manière de lui
dire je t'en prie si tu t'y mets toi
aussi à 2 contre une ça va devenir tueur
ça va aller je t'emmène je sais ce qu'il
te plaît
pour la minceur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et elle a changé ici un nom c'est bien
ce qui fait son charme
ça lui dit on sans rire n tu connais ma
soeur sara j'avais entendu dire que tu
étais là ah bon la nouvelles vont vite
et si j'en arrive
ouais je te présente mes condoléances
pour ton père d'ailleurs s'il vous faut
quoi que ce soit n'hésitez pas sur tout
alors tu es de retour pour de bon sa non
non je suis revenu uniquement pour les
obsèques
c'est pauvre hensley a besoin d'un mec
toutes les semaines je vous les groupes
et de leurs qu'istres et tout le monde
la connaît je parie à sa place je me
cacherais populaire et pas quand on
était ados thorel sommet le chanteur
pour lui piquer son micro sarah tu peux
vraiment être fier de ta soeur quand mon
petit rémy est tombé malade
lily a été là pour nous parti de rien et
rennes rémy travaille bien en classe mon
petit picasso encore une fois n'hésitez
pas à m'appeler
tu as l'air de connaître tout le monde
ici sauf toi tu m'avais pas dit que h
foule et épouser
[Musique]
tu sais je crois que papa et maman non
plus été les mêmes côté partie tabriz et
les choeurs de papa il avait qu'à pas
commencé c'est pour ça que tu es parti
on grandit on devient adulte on a besoin
d'avancer c'est ce que j'ai fait par est
si tu te met à chanter l'histoire de la
vie je te jure que je t'en colle une
réponse mois sarah pape a incarné ce que
j'aimais le plus ici se lever tôt pour
aller observer lés cerfs les barbecues
du dimanche et même son fichu gros
bobard c'est toi que veut baptiser
smitty le bobard à du siècle là j'ai
compris que c'était du vin tout ça il
trompait maman importe quoi de mal avec
une certaine des tirettes s'il te plaît
j'ai retrouvé des lettres aura est mort
tu préfères quoi jouer les poisons ou
les remèdes ici décide débrouille toi
pour entrer lee
les lits
les lits les lis tu pourrais me ramener
à la maison et rennes je suis là jusqu'à
2h mon chou moi j'ai les larmes mais
c'est gentil mais il nous faut quelqu'un
qui connaisse le coin trésor
ça y est j'ai trouvé une solution tyler
ahn fruits ça va sera dans l'air en
forme
toi je te trouve changée oui je porte
des lentilles tyler tu veux bien la
déposer
oui bien sûr
toujours prêt à rendre service garde la
monnaie
je voulais te dire je suis désolée pour
ton père on allait souvent pêcher
ensemble
merci
[Musique]
d'autant c'est la saison des ebooks
grand duc
merci de m'avoir des poussées on aura
l'occasion de se revoir demain aux
obsèques
ouais alors bon soir tu devrais aller se
coucher
j'ai envie de rester là encore un moment
celui-ci grand pour une perse tout père
m'avait demandé en mariage à vendredi
il m'avait donné une simple rose il
savait que je les aimais mais il pouvait
pas m'offrir une douzaine tous les
vendredis pendant 34 ans
même s'il était en voyage il s'est
débrouillé pour que j'aime arous
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
célébrer une vie et rendre un dernier
hommage à notre ami mari et père régis
del rey pts/m est en cela qu je me
souviens de nos nombreuses conversations
au cours desquelles ils m'affirmait
qu'être sensible à la majesté de ceux là
qu'était sa manière à lui de rendre
gloire à dieu il n'assistait pas
fréquemment aux services qui s'y trame
qui placent président avait un lien ce
qui laissait rien et montre ici avec
dieu fait qu'ils connaissaient à travers
ses créations
mais voilà il fallait que j'aie durée
sont maintenant désolé c'est ici que ray
voulais que les gens qu'il aimait se
réunissent autour de lui nous allons
dont lui dire un dernier adieu en
évoquant avec lui l'esprit de ses
ancêtres saxons c'est à nous c'est un
nougat oui alors j'ai envie que je ne
suis plus d'accord
écoute c'est ce qu'il voulait viviane je
sais je sais mais compte tenu des
circonstances de sa mort que bien obligé
de reconnaître que le moins déplacé cela
que c'était une bonne partie de l'est
comme ça il fera tout jamais partie de
lui c'est ce que ray aurait voulu ma
chère viviane jc vous avez raison je
parie que tu aux anges ray
[Musique]
n'est pas
non
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui tu veux que je te dise je regrette
de ne pas avoir pensé à apporter un peu
d'eau de vie pour arroser skaff ça va je
suis sûr ça ne dérangerait pas qu'on
s'amuse un peu tu vas me fit fiq
merci bien mal m'en a pris car j'aime
bien le couple est toutes mes
condoléances merci tyler t'aurais pas vu
sarah si elle est de présenter mes
respects sur la terrasse c'était la
meilleure manière de dire au revoir à
quelqu'un comme ton père a salu tyler je
ne t'ai pas vu à la cérémonie
c'est moi qui éteint le feu c'était un
homme bien
il m'a aidé quand j'étais en prison et
maintenant que je suis en semi liberté
non je plaisante je suis patrouilleur
maritime
sap a l'air d'être impressionné j'ai
aussi un business touristique qui marche
bien je fais le gigolo l'été avec les
vieilles estivante les et soleil mais
sexy arrête petite flasque c'est des
coups taf l'atlante et odieux
sarah autrefois lorsque tu es partie oui
d'ailleurs il faut que j'y aille
tu t'en vas déjà je peux faire quelque
chose
non ça m'a fait plaisir de te revoir
mais mon avion décolle dans quelques
heures
non ils t'envoient pas ça une affaire à
régler s'il veut pas m'abandonner s'il
te plaît lits en moins capable de penser
aux autres ne serait ce qu'un petit
instant ça va ça suffit il faut vraiment
que chilien en fuite ont encore vas-y tu
en veux un papa et du coup je perds une
soeur non c'est toi qui les en repartant
et les atavismes et à ton boulot pépère
alors que moi je suis coincé ici avec
maman quoi qu'il ait pu faire ne nous
fait pas payer ou deux on n'y est pour
rien et moi
[Musique]
on
béni soit les vieux bouilleurs de cru et
ce gentil de faire plaisir à votre
vieille mère j'en aurai assez pour
angers tu parles petit il y mettait
encore plus soul que nous deux réunis je
soigne le mal par le mal je n'ai que
deux jours pour être en forme pour le
festival n'est plus là vous aimez
tellement toutes les deux à la fac
un jour on m'a appelé pour me dire que
j'avais reçu un gros bouquet de fleurs
j'étais tout excité je me demandais qui
avait bien pu l'envoyer et c'était papa
évidemment tu ne l'as jamais remercié
celles été dur c'est pas aussi simple
que ça papa et elle tu ne sais pas tout
sur les il avait un grand rêve tout
simple
il voulait élever ses fils en leur
apprenant à chasser à pêcher et ensuite
perdre arriver toutes les deux
j'ai l'impression qu'un orage se prépare
ça manque tant elle est je crois qu on
ferait bien de rentrer
attends je viens
et l'intérêt c'est que c'est une chaleur
sèche 1 en arizona c'est ce qu'on dit
c'est une chaleur sèche et je crois
qu'elle partira très vite
quoi donc la maison va y mettre le feu
c'est ça elle peut parfaitement se raser
quoi une maison ça peut se démolir une
fois je connais j'ai pas envie que notre
maison soit démolie en tout cas j'ai
besoin de 117 mille dollars
et quand on n'a pas une telle somme
d'argent sous la main la solution de
l'appartement est très raisonnable
ce que tu t'y es ce que tu dis ran show
d'elmander si j'ai été séduite aussi
vite et à cause d'une sauce tomate du
même nom peu trop possible tu vas pas
vendre la maison qu'est ce que je ferais
ici tout seul serait totalement perdu
temps je te signale que j'y vis encore
au trésor tu m'as bien fait comprendre
que tu partirais faire l'école des
beaux-arts
pourquoi je serai la seule à rester dans
cette maison c'est insensé
sarah tu aura intérêt à venir me voir un
l'arizona c'est à côté de la californie
si je ne m'abuse qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
elle a déjà contacté une agence
[Musique]
oh
papa je ne pensais pas que tu aurais
legrand de m'affronter
tu te souviens quand j'étais petit
j'allais voulu traduire ces lacs à la
rame tout seul tu m'avais récupérer tu
n'avais que ces temps et était déjà très
sûr de toi
bien sûr tu étais trop petit pour te
servir des rames mais avait dû 1 et
avant qu'on comprenne monte et est parti
c'était déjà 3 400 m ils étaient
terrorisés j'avais une peur bleue j'ai
sauté dans l'eau j'ai nagé jusqu'à toi
pendant que toiture y est de me voir
barboter ans chercheur grimper dans la
barque juillet mois quand la barque a
chaviré
j'avais peur que ce midi nous attrapent
des revenus sur la berge en portant sur
temps doux et pendant un bon quart
d'heure tu va serrer très fort c'est bon
de voir mon chat
et en fait comment tu peux boire oui
c'est pas génial ça c'est arrivé comment
c'était un accident
crois moi ça peut être rien d'autre un
truc pareil j'en ai même perdu mon
chapeau je mourrai train
[Musique]
je leur ai mangé la bouche toujours
grande ouverte si vous rendez deuil mais
trois élégante dame du lac
3 c'est tout il y aurait pas d'autres
dames qui aurait compté des obsèques
dieu par lâcher brûle à penser à maman à
toutes ces années de mensonges
comme si une rose tous les vendredis
pouvait compenser engins décidément tu
n'es pas vraiment et je rentrais à la
maison ramène moi
les willard t'ont apporté des pancakes
aux pépites de chocolat et le beurre de
cacahuète amant sans façon je l'aimé je
sentais préféré way
peut-être quand j'avais 8 ans nouvelles
techniques artistiques
ça m'aide à organiser mon esprit pour
m'ouvrir aux cadeaux de l'univers c'est
ça que tu peins ce moment j'aime bien
plutôt minimaliste
c'était pour papa il voulait que je
capture ce panorama du lac
ma seule et unique commandes je
remettais je remettais rien ne presse
maintenant ça c'est tout à fait toi oh
je sais ce que je suis un professeur de
province qui peint des villes qu'elle
n'ira jamais visité je suis même pas
allé à chicago j'aurais dû brûler mon
portfolio quand j'en ai eu l'occasion
quoi j'avais la bouteille de gaz à la
main papam on a empêché
il a dit que l'étoile pouvait servir il
en a fait don à l'église pour un vide
greniers elles ont été réutilisés par
des amateurs
et c'est tant mieux je croyais que tu
aimes est enseignée ouais j'aime bien
j'aime les enfants mais pouvoir des
écoliers de 10 ans dessiner des robots
et moi ou bien moi en robot je veux dire
que c'est pas tout à fait comme ça que
je voyais ma vie tu comprends
je me prends bien trop la tête
il faut que je réveille makonda ligny et
que j'ouvre mon chakra du coeur si tous
sous les cieux arrive à voir la beauté
en tant que tel c'est parce qu'il y a de
la laideur si un jour tu laisses tomber
l'enseignement qui pourra toujours
écrire des textes pour des biscuits
chinois
vous serez très bientôt accoudé à un bar
avec plusieurs vieux amis au lit
[Musique]
[Rires]
allo
karl burger lui même vous m'avez envoyé
68 mais marc thurman à l'appareil
exploration se termine mince alors
monsieur vous êtes monsieur on a un
problème à cause d'une annulation
alors j'aimerais venir avec une équipe
faire une émission sur ce midi nous pour
de vrai c'est carrément
pourquoi tu ne vais pas parler de quoi
rembourser c'est impossible
tu m'avais promis qu'on vieillit réussi
aux hommes les tuer par guillaume les
autres tout seul
chérie après 34 ans passés ensemble
tu as vraiment le sentiment d'être seul
nom ou non d'ailleurs c'est peut-être en
partie le problème je te retrouve
partout un ebook dans notre lit cette
cabane que tu as construit ma maison ça
toujours été toi mais c'était la maison
des filles
alors si tu crois devoir partir elle
pour entêté et fille lily se sent coincé
ici à cause de moi et sarah cherche
surtout à fuir par le premier avion
[Musique]
maman pourquoi tu vends la maison est ce
que tu crois que le joie rap tuerie
maubé j'ai déjà vu ce nom quelque part
où paraît que les vrais propriétaires
c'est euh tu as 2 semaines pour payer
sinon tu seras expulsé en plus cette
lettre date d'il ya dix jours mais enfin
pourquoi tu me l'a pas montré tout de
suite je ne l'avais pas encore trouvé
mais papa avait remboursé son emprunt
quand on était petit
tu sais un jour il bâtit aussi foncier à
sale cuisine qui te plaît alors il a
refinancé le crédit auprès des bailleurs
sa porte jamais vraiment entendu parler
de ces gens là de capture s'ils
n'arrivent pas à vendre la maison pour
les payer tu me retrouve sans rien maman
je trouverais une solution
[Musique]
allo jean sahara mais où êtes vous les
gens de textile internationales seront
là dans une
j'ai essayé de vous joindre mais je n'ai
pas de réseau et si je suis coincé j'ai
raté mon avion je vois je vous fais une
nouvelle réservation non je n'entre pas
tout de suite
pardon mais winchester va péter les
plombs si vous n'êtes pas en briefings
je peux remplacer
écoutez il ya une carte sur mon bureau
au nom de rap tueur immobilier dites-moi
qui est derrière le plus vite possible
d'accord merci à jean hey vous êtes une
perle
[Musique]
à
une hausse y est aussi
[Musique]
comment veux tu que je retrouve quoi que
ce soit le temps
[Musique]
elles sont toujours là les seniors qui
font du jet ski
[Musique]
je me demande ce qu'elle attendait de la
vie au montage
[Musique]
comment rap tueur s'est retrouvé dans
tout ça
[Musique]
ils sont partout autour du lac
ça va encore un document officiel
ah merci beaucoup quel beau chemisier
magnifiques couleurs merci saura taille
là qu'est ce que tu fais là je te
croyais parti c'est que je dois régler
quelques problèmes à propos de la
succession de mon père tu as l'air
stressé tu viens manger un morceau
tyler j'ai un petit ami je n'ai pas dit
que je l'invitais lui j'ai un permis à
déposer j'en ai pour deux secondes tu
bouges pas je reviens j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi est-ce que tu as
choisi d'être patrouilleur maritime
ici à smith l'antenne lake j'adore
mettre des pv aux contrevenants mais le
mégaphone
ça c'est la vraie raison sérieusement
non il ya une magie propre à ce lac pour
rien au monde de s'unir et ailleurs toi
aussi tu disais que tu ne partirai
jamais et juste quand ça allait devenir
sérieux entre nous tu es parti à la fac
oui mais je t'ai appelé tous des mêmes
écrit je t'avais changer de rythme alors
je suis parti j'ai un aveu à te faire je
t'ai vu l'autre soir chercher à sauter
du haut de la terrasse
j'essaie événement d'avoir du réseau
pour mon portable j'ai surpris des gars
qui étaient au spectacle faute de voir
le bobard du siècle ils n'auront pas
tout à fait perdu leur soirée
l'acheteur trouve totalement
ça y est vous avez choisi oui je vais
prendre un sandwich au porc rôti des
oignons frits avec un thé glacé et vos
jeunes filles une petite salade et de
l'eau citronnée
un bouteille d'eau j'y reviens
et comment va ta mère elle tient le coup
elle veut vendre la maison
elle voudrait aller vivre en arizona la
chaleur est sèche là bas
et voilà
excuse moi je dois y aller je comprends
maintenant comment tu fais pour rester
si mince tu manges rien laisse moi te
faire à dîner un soir
tyler
je rêve la succession de mon père et
après j'ai peur
la rue en janvier elle arrive russell
avec un seul l aube où un seul elle
c'est la moins ces peuples
je peux avoir un autographe ouais ça je
m'en occuperai dit monsieur feterman
s'il vous plaît comment ça se fait que
votre façon d'être et de parler soit pas
la même à la télévision que dans la
vraie vie pour l'émission j'ai recours à
des dialectes comme ça et
téléspectateurs se disent que c'est
quelqu'un comme eux qui leur raconte une
histoire
vous comprenez c'est hollywood quoi bon
je vais faire quelques interviews que je
montrais avec des plans choisis dans
notre banque de données si vous tapez
entrée sur l'ordinateur
vous verrez des images de l'émission
tournée à new fang langues sur la
créature créée si on a des tonnes de
monstres sur fond vert à match et avec
votre là qu'en gros on place la créature
vous savez pas de quoi elle a l'air on
s'en fiche on n'aura jamais les vraies
images du monstre c'est pour ça qu'on
fait dire constitution enfin les gars on
n'est pas la radio il faut montrer du
visuel aux gens c'est très bien
dit avec mes copains on va prendre un
verre dans le coin ça vous dit venir non
non je passe mon tour
ouais il y avait longtemps que je
n'avais pas autant d j'aime bien venir
ici il ya du monde fait toujours animé
c'est aujourd'hui je déjeunais avec
tyler et la petite coquine elle raconte
j'ai retrouvé betty elle est serveuse
dans un restaurant en filet comment tu
peux être tellement sûrs qu'elles
existent à cause des lettres je peux
piémont plus long je crois pas ton
histoire c'est cela que cette vie qui
sont authentiques et pas une illusion
hors du temps en temps tu vis dans un
piège et le piège s'est refermé pourquoi
tu viens pas elle est avec moi oui ce
serait génial de laisser maman
maintenant oui je n'y a qu' on a encore
combien de temps tu vas te cacher
derrière maman allez les enfants on va
réveiller notre kundalini et ouvrir
votre chakra du coeur comme ça tu ne
risques surtout pas d'essuyer une vraie
critique redire que je suis vraiment
désolé c'est pas grave c'est pas la
première bière qui finit sur moi mais la
dernière
merci big c bet c'était la chine tient
car tu as rencontré un mega man se
préparait c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire monsieur marc petermann de la
chaîne explorateurs il va faire des
révélations sur ce métier pour des vrais
dit tu permets que je te l'année ah oui
quoi pour lui montrer où la légende a
commencé oui bien sûr papa on serait
tellement fière sainte et les gars sort
c'est vraiment très gentil de leur part
de nous avoir accompagnés tu as raison
très gentil on y est presque
j'avais oublié les escaliers grâce à eux
j'ai jamais à m'inscrire dans un club de
gym didon ça doit te faire bizarre de
revenir ici m'adapter citadine chic il
t'amène tout le temps à des fêtes qui
saïd un petit avocat par dix et bien
l'élu
il est l'élu mais ça j'en sais rien
haché il devrait l'être mais tu sais
c'est un vrai avocat
alors qu'est ce que tu fais avec lui il
est intelligent drôle et wahaha
moi je vois ces six toiles on n'envoie
pas des comme ça l est je suis désolée
pour ce que je t'ai dit tout à l'heure
je ne pensais pas
et c'est vrai pourtant je suis un
poisson moyens dans une toute toute
petite mare enfin dans un lac plus tôt
j'ai bien à l'abri à l'abri et ennuyeuse
il s'il ya bien quelque chose que tu ne
seras jamais
[Musique]
merci de me recevoir de si bon matin
monsieur boillon comme vous le savez mon
père avait refinancer son crédit chez
vous mais d'après la chaîne de titres
rap tuerait le vrai propriétaire de sa
maison
votre père est venu me trouver il ya
trois ans ils avaient besoin de fonds
pour faire certaines rénovations cadeau
à viviez dans qu'il a pris un crédit
hypothécaire
cette région a été durement frappé par
la récession bien des gens se sont
trouvés surendettés et ne pouvait plus
faire face rapt sûrs enfin rap tueur
nous a assuré qu'ils traiteraient ces
gens comme leur propre famille alors oui
nous leur avons vendu un groupe de prêts
pour une perte acceptable en tant que
créance hypothécaire et maintenant ils
veulent être remboursés comme la loi les
y autorise
ma mère n'a pas une somme pareille et
ils veulent la forcer à vendre à perte
je ne peux pas les obliger à tenir
parole
je suis désolé si je pouvais c'est avec
joie que j'arrange rsa
merci merci bonjour j'ai voulu
rassembler quelques personnes et leur
dire que tu te renseigner ce rap tuerie
modelage au sahara j'étais en train de
dire à votre mère que pour nous ça a
commencé quand elle s'est blessée au
pied qu'il a dû quitter la police les
factures se sont accumulés monsieur
byers n'a pas pu nous aider c'était trop
risqué
c'est la capture est arrivée nous a
offert une porte de sortie pareil pour
le bas je pouvais pas bosser j'étais
tout le temps à l'hôpital avec montremy
j'ai dû faire un deuxième emprunts pour
payer sa radiothérapie alors arthur
s'est présenté en juin les anges
gardiens rap tueur c'est pas des anges
je serais plutôt rap old immobilier vous
avez connu comment il avait mis des
affiches sur un panneau à l'hôpital j'ai
pas compris à l'époque y avait un vice
un type est passé au magasin s'il ne se
passe rien dans les prochains mois je
serai obligé de vendre comme vous viviez
[Musique]
drap tuerie monde et ça en fait des
planes contre eux en une année
c'est gentil de me rappeler je vous en
prie ferrat mais je dois vous dire qu'on
s'était déjà intéressé rap tueur et
qu'on n'a jamais trouvé de quoi monter
un dossier
il s'est clairement de manipuler le
marché bonne chance pour réussir à le
prouver
laissez moi au moins vous montrer ce que
j'ai trouvé bon je vous accorde 10
minutes demain à 17h au cas j'y serai
salut mon petit car quelles nouvelles de
la montagne tu t'es pas fait kidnapper
par un ruban de soie méchant c'est pas
la dernière à les critiquer c'est ma
famille la plupart des gens ici te salue
quand on les croise en voiture et il se
plierait tous en quatre pour te rendre
service je te jure t devrait voir ça ce
sera pour une autre fois on est submergé
par cette fusion ma chérie quand tu
reviendras on se rattrapera manger le
carpaccio de l'enquêté non c'est toi qui
en est fou alors on ira où tu vouloir ça
doit mais rentrer le plus vite possible
je dois m'occuper de rap tueur
immobilier avant dernière chose en fait
je voudrais pas que tu mélanges business
et le privé mais ils ont de soi disant
client tout autour du lac
ils rachètent des crédits à la banque
font grimper les intérêts et fort ses
emprunteurs à vendre à découvert
tu es sûr de pouvoir porter plainte au
pénal contre eux j'ai rendez vous chez
procurerait acheter toujours là oui
absolument d'un petit coupé je t'écoute
mais c'est quoi cette histoire de pénale
contre eux tu es là ça
et merde
ça lui vaut je suis aujourd'hui un smith
mountain lake en virginie alors car
selon vous une ville entière sera enfoui
au fond du lac
quelques maisons tout du mois marc
petermann cimetière aussi des habitants
qui ne voulaient pas croire que le
niveau de l'eau montrait autant ont dû
abandonner tout ce qu'ils possédaient
car le burger est le président d'une
société de recherche sur la créature du
lac un plésiosaure géant qui l'a
surnommé smitty que pouvez-vous nous
dire sur cette bête qu on va couper 1
pour commencer on se détend à fond ça a
marché
quand je vous poserai la question
détendez vous pensez ça ira c'est bon
soyez positif sur l'irl axe ne regardez
pas la caméra ne répétez pas mon nom à
tous chants là ça devient ridicule
on y va alors qu'arles que pouvez-vous
me dire sur la bête et bien marc furman
ce midi c'est comme ça qu'ils avaient
été baptisés par un vieil ami pêcheur il
l'avait appelé smitty on pense qu'il ya
plusieurs centaines d'années et qu'il
pèse plus de deux tonnes
on dirait ma belle-mère ça tu coupes
évidemment lilly oui monde sarah
bravo pour panneaux arrachés qu'est ce
que tu as
il les avait soi-disant donné à un vide
greniers
[Musique]
à
comment tu as pu vouloir brûler ses
toiles tu te dis oui
ça génial qu'elle allait prendre
souviens de ce que tu disais à propos
des cadeaux de l'univers auquel il faut
s'ouvrir mais pas alors oui bon d'accord
maintenant si on allait voir comment
sauver la maison tu viens ou pas ouais
j'arrive à cran
[Musique]
pourquoi tu m'a reparlé du sauvetage
pour te rappeler cet enfant qu'il
n'avait peur de rien je suis parti tout
seul à l'ailé
justement tu es parti tout seul et voilà
que maintenant il y en a beaucoup qui ne
reculerait devant rien pour t'empêcher
de renouer avec tes proches
ce n'est qu'une supposition et pendant
votre honneur tout le monde a ses petits
secrets
tu devrais le savoir de quoi tu pas bâti
une sacrée dégringolade comparé à maman
qu'est-ce qu'elle avait bien pu offrir
le plat du jour à volonté j'ai retrouvé
les lettres d'eads ead au sahara si ça
n'avait pas été célèbre c'est autre
chose qui t'aurait perturbé ramène moi
maintenant t'es à côté de la plaque
je sais que tu as écrit sa lettre c'est
vrai je les ai écrites
toutes sans exception tu t'imagines que
tu as tout compris
tu devrais regarder d'un peu plus près
réac une nuit c'est trop demander une
seule vraie nuit de sommeil
[Musique]
bonjour
vous êtes venus voir la maison oh vous
la vendez je pars pour l'arizona aux
minces
c'est vrai que là bas la chaleur est
sèche
je suis vraiment désolé pour votre mari
je m'appelle d'authie price
je tient la boutique de cadeaux à la
marina vous connaissez diddy bondurant
j'espère que vous resterez ici venez
vous voulez monter volontiers
certainement c'est assez vieillot mais
s'est vendu en l'état il ne faut pas
acheter cette maison c'est une maison
hantée liquide
je vous demande de m'excuser en fait on
n'était pas venus voir la maison nord
on était venu vous inviter à vous
joindre à notre groupe de jet skieuse je
suis pas trop fan de honsel nuit pas à
ça tout autour du lac n'ont par exemple
on aide aussi à l'organisation du
festival du vin veux j'en sais rien
beaucoup d'entre nous sont veuves
j'ai perdu harbi six mois après notre
arrivée ici tendre la main aux autres
c'est bien mieux que rester chez soi on
serait ravis que vous puissiez nous
aider à accrocher les tableaux exposés
au festival
alors monsieur matte garenne quelle est
votre opinion vous croyez à l'existence
de serpent du lat
en tant que président du comité du
festival du vagin je suis très heureux
d'apporter ma contribution à cette
question mais je ne sais que vous dire
je suis ennuyé c'est bon il serait ma
position officielle c'est que ce mythe y
existe ma position personnelle c'est
qu'il n'existe pas cela dit ma position
publique et que puisque les gens d'ici
aiment ce serpent de mer par conséquent
moi aussi alors quand est ce quand tu
vois même nom mais sa tournée je
préviens pas idiot si vous mettez le
bazar dans mon festival du vin coupé
coupé moi ça
[Musique]
non c'est une blague t'indiquer
réservoir plein quand je suis parti papa
est à fusées éclairantes au secours à
quelqu'un
j'ai pris un vol de nuit pour la
virginie aussi mais qui soulève bien
tout ce coup là bas je dois m'occuper
d'un éventuel litige
[Musique]
les ruraux sont complètement dingue je
vous les 24 heures hb lancre de votre
contrat n'est pas encore sèche donc s'il
ne venait pas de retour d'ici 24 heures
vous êtes viré tous les deux je ferai de
mon mieux monsieur mais j'ai un gps qui
ne marche pas d'accord celui ci c'était
un lama
allo
[Musique]
allez on essaie de pas bavarder compris
merci on y va après on va pouvoir y
aller car on a ce qu'il nous faut avec
vous et la banda smitty d'accord je peux
tenir le micro mais merci ça va aller je
crois qu'on maîtrise encore merci
c'était formidable vraiment un super
super super merci
excusez moi mais parfait celle qui est à
mes côtés n'est autre que lily tisdale
c'est à dire la fille de rei tisdale le
premier à avoir vu celui qui vous vous
l'avez vu ce monstre eh bien je me
souviens d'un soir où mon père avait
pêché tard et ma mère commençaient à
s'inquiéter quand il a fini par rentrer
ils étaient trempés jusqu'aux os et il a
dit qu'un lézard géant avait fait
chavirer son bateau smitty oui il a dit
qu'il faisait comme ça alors dites moi
une chose c'était quoi vous pensez qu il
devait être saoul il avait chaviré tout
seul j'espère que tu l'as eu gelé à
l'hélice était magnifique ses serveurs
ont formidablement sur le petit écran
dernier vous êtes très naturel alors ce
qu'on va faire c'est que je vais vous
donner ma carte
et c'est quoi que ce soit d'autre vous
revenez vous m'appelez sans hésiter
n'est d'ailleurs steve a encore du
travail ici il doit faire des transferts
vidéo reprendre les sons va des trucs
techniques mais moi je suis obligé de
repasser au motel vous pourriez me
emmener
bien sûr oui producteurs je vais emmener
un chaperon non inutile tu es génial
vous pouvez pas des sages steve merci
maman tu peux raccompagné le petit
voisin
ça va ça va sarah lane de moteurs teller
quelle chance j'arrive pas à démarrer
peuvent les sens la jauge disait cui en
tout cas un le central je suis avec une
bleue qui évoque bien mystérieux
syndrome de bateaux handicapés on va
leur manquer j'ai rendez vous au cabinet
du procureur ap j'ai l'impression et
puis d'ailleurs j'étais sauvé la vie tu
me dois dîner et un prix tu sais ce qui
aurait pu arriver si j'étais papa c'est
vilain coup de soleil poisson chat géant
et radioactif qui sait bobards du siècle
à aller on a gagné ce mac line aller
monte
[Musique]
bonjour vous pouvez m'indiquer la route
pour scott seconde où je serai plus
facile de vous y conduire comme nous
l'expliqué c'est plus rapide plan que la
secousse avait un bateau il ya une tête
avoir un bateau non juste ont une tête
avoir un grossier comportement
[Musique]
on
fecteau
[Musique]
heureusement que vous m'avez déposé je
me serais perdu sinon on y est voilà je
te laisse le siège extra la voiture oui
c'est moi qui l'ait fait merci de
m'avoir fait participer ma mère sera
hystérique quand elle me verra de rien
c'était un plaisir
vous semblez destinés à vivre de plus
grandes choses merci qu'est ce que vous
diriez de monter dans ma chambre boire
un verre ça vous tente
volontiers mais j'ai un travail à
terminer et je tiens à rester concentrés
sérieux ça je les sentais que je vous ai
vu bien je vais vous dire demain avant
le tournage du lac vous me donnerez des
détails sur cette bande de gaza et tous
les deux c'est à dire vous et moi on ira
dîner ensemble ça vous va je vais
je prends ça poids oui un oui servi sur
un lit de weir ainsi avec une coupe de
huy alors à demain
bonsoir c'est vraiment nul comme
chaperon tu sais ça
ça sent bon c'est du bar des petites
pommes de terre et une bonne bouteille
de viognier va locale je croyais que par
local on entendait forcément alcool de
contrebande
il ya une vingtaine de viticulteurs dans
la région et ça qu'est ce que c'est et
pierre que je trouve en plongeant c'est
pour un autre livre que j'ai écrit un
autre
techniquement j'ai pris une année
sabbatique au boulot je suis prof de fac
à virginia tech
mon premier livre est là il ne menant
l'autre reflet du lac ondulations
infinie par le docteur tyler en france
ma thèse de doctorat d'une prétention
hallucinant retrait mais tout le monde
m'appelle payent leur eau j'ai trouvé ça
ça devrait te plaire
c'est ma couleur préférée oui je m'en
souvenais
non attends ça suffit allez un petit
dernier
je te parlerai des ruines lac est assez
dangereux il ya des endroits où on peut
s'accrocher en plongeant vieux fils
barbelés ou branches d'arbres la
visibilité est très mauvaise mais quand
on croit en avoir fait le tour
il faut regarder de plus près
imagine pas ce qu'il ya au fond et à des
maisons avec des tas de conserve dans
les garde manger toutes ces ruines pour
créer un lac se sublime lac alors tir
venu pour ça j'essaie de faire honneur
aux gens qui vivaient là
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais belle nuit pour se
baigner froid de canard
tu viens ah non ah oui j'oubliais c'est
vrai que ma porte et plus d'ici
chan bleus d'accord c'est parti taylor
j'ai un petit ami
et est ce qui paraît
et
[Musique]
e
lô et carentan ya forcément quelqu'un
dans un de ses atouts bonjour bonjour
dieu soit loué quelqu'un est réveillé
mon gps est mort est-ce que je suis à
smith mountain par la ja non c'est de
l'autre côté du lac
qu'est ce que vous faites là cherchez
pas il faut vous dire que je viens de
passer la nuit à guetter l'arrivée des
gars de délivrance vous pouvez me dire
où c'est bien sûr c'est plus rapide par
le lac vous avez un bateau est ce que
j'ai une tête non j'en ai pas bon très
bien alors vous allez rouler pendant 10
suivez-moi l'intérieur un bon café une
carte vous remettrons d'éclaircies
[Musique]
donc nous on est ici et vous voulez
aller là vous permettez que je
allez-y
tyler je peux savoir ce que mon
soutien-gorge faisaient ce sera c'est
pas vrai qu'est-ce que tu fiches là moi
non mais c'est toi qu'est ce que tu fais
la presse à l'autre j'ai dû faire
remarquer mon bateau et j'ai pas pu
rentrer chez moi à la fois qu'elle peut
tout faire
h
prédateur froid
attends une minute c'était pas le
prédateur été la proie
un tueur immobilier d'où ça sort
rabdhure génère en outre d'énormes
revenus tuera présentera pictures
immobilier c'est pour ça que tu es venu
oui rap tueur j'ai fait ça pour toi pour
que tu es des clients dans sa ville
natale
je pouvais pas savoir qu'il détenait le
crédit de tes parents maintenant
ramasser des affaires il monte dans la
voiture je suis même prêt à te pardonner
ton aventure et ce tous eu à me
pardonner
va-t'en h tu ne m'auras pas je ne repars
pas sans toi tu as totalement ruiné ma
mère comment on peut être aussi inhumain
h va chasser ailleurs prédateurs et si
le terme ne trouvait rien du tout
commence à s'y trouver un jeans il
installe toutes ces caméras et ses
projecteurs et que ce meeting se montre
pas il l'a expliqué c'est là qu'ils font
venir la police scientifique la raison
on sait comment ça se passe avec lui il
nous fera passer pour un tas de douilles
on ne laissera personne nous ridiculiser
faut se débrouiller pour qu'ils voient
quelque chose
ouais
et comment
[Applaudissements]
je crois que j'ai un plan je l'aurais eu
tu sais après ça cogneuse allons prendre
un p'tit déj
non désolé il faut manger un peu gtoi y
aller non attends attends
avant que tu ne reprenne la fuite sans
même en donner la raison
laisse moi au moins battre toutes les
cartes je t'aime sarran je t'ai toujours
aimé toujours
si tu pouvais le lire au fond de mon
coeur
[Musique]
je peux tyler farrar
pour karl ça va être une sacrée surprise
il faut se dépêcher la mener seul truc
sur la rive en route a les cheveux
terrebonne qui voulaient du sme et et on
va te née du smi dit doucement en fait
gaffe nobi nobi
qu'est ce qu'il ya
[Musique]
irène la fille du bar m'a dit que tu
t'étais disputé avec h lente
ça va aller ça va aller geci la branche
sur laquelle j'étais m'attaquer à
capture s'était attaqué à mon cabinet
j'étais bien parti pour être nommé
associé sauf qu'après je ne pourrai plus
jamais faire face à winchester je suis
très fier de ce que tu as accompli chez
v
je sais que tu ne voulais pas venir
comme moi non
c'est pas pour ça que je suis parti si
tu me dis c'est ce que tu as à me dire
sarah j'ai tu te sens obligé de te
retenir sous prétexte que tu m'as vu
m'enfoncer dans un chagrin profond
j'aimais tout père de tout cas je ne
suis pas si fragile
oui j'ai choisi cette vie j'ai choisi de
privilégier la famille la communauté la
simplicité de la nature plutôt que la
richesse le pouvoir une carrière où la
gloire
moi je respecte ses choix alors que dans
ta ville les gens ne respectent pas les
miens mais j'attends plus de jugeote de
ta part
j'ai toujours dit qu'il fallait aller
droit au but et savoir te battre alors
respire à mon cou est en toi et ensuite
dit lui quel moment ce que tu as à lui
dire c'est comme ça que tu dois procéder
avec monsieur winchester je n'ai pas
pour habitude de négocier avec mes
propres employés mais je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir s'arranger m teasdale
convoqué moi monsieur winchester je suis
prêt à convenir que h aurait dû faire
preuve d'une plus grande prudence avant
d'accepter rap tueur comme clients
comment éviter une procédure pénale en
renonçant à ses droits sur la maison de
viviane teasdale d'accord et en prenant
en charge six mois de son emprunt à la
banque
à titre de dédommagement d'accord le
même traitement devant s'appliquer à
l'épicerie thinel s'étaient entendus y
at il autre chose
votre client tire un trait sur smith
montagne lake évidemment ça vaut pour
l'ensemble de l'état de virginie
échange vous obtiendrez d'engager la
moindre procédure contre rap tueur fou
la citrouille latéral vert pour quelques
infractions que ce soit relevant de sa
responsabilité
complet vous êtes une bonne juriste
sarah votre force sont vos valeurs
alors rentré immédiatement la corée pour
ashland ces personnes ne fait plus
partie du cabinet on a réussi
[Musique]
je l' ai fini apple aurait tellement
aimé telligent mes chers concitoyens
des dizaines d'hommes et en virginie
vous a tant servi à la pression on
parlera n'ont pas la pression c'est pour
la ville je veux dire qui décante ont
donné corps pas selon déjà fait qu'ils
respirent sondés offert t-il pour ce
métier paris
[Musique]
ban
beaucoup
elizabeth
excuses au titre cela avec au site
retenu ah si j'avais votre silhouette je
mangerai aussi comme un oiseau comment
avez vous connu mon père
rae était un ami à une période où bien
peu de gens m'ont tendu la main
un ami un ami de quel genre
je n'avais pas ce qu'on appelle une
bonne réputation mais je ne méritais pas
un homme comme wallonne rema sorti de là
il m'a même payé une chambre
il m'a accompagné chez le médecin
j'ignorais tout cette histoire
vous étiez trop jeune à l'époque pour
savoir ces choses je lui en serai
éternellement reconnaissante et il ne
vous a jamais donné de surnoms non
il ya bien des gens qui m'appellent lisa
mais j'ai horreur de ça je préfére
elisabeth elizabeth
alors qui est petit petit
via au bord du lac le type
d'explorateurs tourne encore pour la
télé déjà on observe souvent des
mouvements par ici évidemment on n'a pas
du matériel comme le ventre non
évidemment
c'est lui carl toi tu me plais ma belle
mélissa suis prêt ok on va faire un truc
alors que le compte à rebours et tourne
à 5 4 3 2 je suis avec call ce soir au
bord du lac de smith mountain envir jeu
back et doit être expédiée
je répète le touquet ce que vous
entendez mais qu'est ce que c'est d'être
excusez moi oui vous merci on aimerait
enregistrer du son s il vous plait
et là où vous pouvez baisser dans le
temps on va là vous allez marseille
n'avait rien on y va ça tourne
je suis avec karl ce soir au bord du lac
de smith mountain en virginie pour
tenter d'apercevoir ce monstre qui vit
au fond de long d'après les habitants tu
as vu le terme app l'adoré
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs observée très
attentivement l'horizon grâce à nos
moyens modernes vous allez voir pour la
toute première fois un monstre lacustre
j'aime faire demi-tour et comment ça tu
peux pas c'est bien toi qui attaché non
non non ça pouvait tourner qu'elle
s'était posée par quelque chose quoi
tout le mal à cacher ce soir j'aimerais
vous présenter nos excuses et moi -
jamais votre attention s'il nous avons
miss virginie ce soir à pau
bonsoir
[Musique]
et
j'ai l'impression que c'est mes amis va
bouger de chez vous payer la tête de
marc fues comme un challenge me
permettre à monsieur
l'arrêté
non attendez
je partais pas marion
[Musique]
au carl t'aurais dû m'en parler je sais
faire un très méchant smitty
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu me crois qu'en plus de ça c'est bon
allez c'est juste un truc en ferraille
assurément un acte d'amour pourra alors
vraiment c'était pas du tout au courant
non il n'empêche que je vais pas me
fâcher avec ses 3 pour une malheureuse
bêtise de parfaits débile je sais qu'ils
ont bon coeur
je leur dois au moins d'écouter leurs
explications de leur rendement
[Musique]
mais
sage désolé d'avoir appris pour votre
père enfin désolé de ce qui est arrivé
pas de fait d'avoir appris je veux dire
votre père avait des relations dans
chaque ville ou écoutez je crois que
miss virginie a besoin de vous monsieur
le président excusez moi d'avoir
officiellement m'y reprendra à répondre
à ce genre de mail vous n'aurez pas tout
perdu magnifique vue excellent vin
habitants et là une brochure touristique
une visite gratuite ça vous intéresse
vous est destiné à vivre de grandes
choses discutons
[Musique]
eco vous êtes marié mange non ingérence
et non plus petit ami non je n'ai pas
non plus de petit ami
tant mieux j'ai mon petit fils de 26 ans
qui serait parfait bon oui si vous avez
soif
[Musique]
normalement crash pourquoi gaspiller
ainsi bon vin
[Musique]
vous savez qu'il a pas c'est moi qui ai
fait ce tableau il est extraordinaire
combien vous en demandez je regrette
mais il n'est pas à vendre
j'aime ses couleurs chatoyantes
si vous changez d'avis dites le moi
après tout c'est ont jamais entendu je
vais ouvrir une galerie d'art à l'entrée
de la marina j'aimerais vous commandez
un tableau de ce genre le paysage que je
vois de ma maison
merci
[Musique]
ils ont
faux
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu sais que d'authie vam installer une
espèce d'ateliers au fond de sa galerie
et elle a des contacts avec des
galeristes à washington rentré chez moi
au nom lui tenu beauté oui est ce qui
s'est passé est tard et ça c'est moi
l'attirail monsieur spielberg
si vous voulez bien minute papillon et
les filles avec mon grand vie comparé à
la pêche alors grand vide qu'est ce
qu'on prend comme un pas que de la
meilleure qualité
je comprends pas pourquoi ils te
laissais comme ça c'est moi qu'il
mettait dehors
un homme a besoin de voir ses copains
c'est naturel je faisais autant il avait
une maîtresse sahara tout le temps de
voir marié un chef du cpq une certaine
betty
avant que vous ne veniez au monde
on travaillait tous les deux dans la
distribution et ray était sur les routes
constamment et alors quand il était en
voyage on avait pris l'habitude de
s'écrire et il s'était mis en tête de
mât plus betty comme betty boop s'était
travesti
tu ne t'es jamais demandé pourquoi des
lettres adressées à une autre femme
avait atterri dans mon grenier mais
celle-là traits sont elles sont
oui je veux vous n'êtes pas tout seul
des boutons j'ai raté tous vos
anniversaires
j'ai manqué tout haut je trouvais que
sort et hypocrite au des petites
[Musique]
papa
comment j'ai pu croire que petit existe
il te fallait peut-être trouvé ta propre
ordre
ce n'était rien fait que je n'ai plus
jamais faux fois que je te prennent plus
hautes et bien sûr que si et avait sans
doute besoin de croire à l'existence de
cette betty pour trouver en tout cas
toute la force et le feu qui te pousse
cette aventure et dans le monde mais je
t'aimais si tu savais à quel point
je t'aime tant ma chérie
ben d'identité retrouvée et moi ils
l'avaient cherché tout autour du bac es
tu dirais tout ira bien mon petit chat
tout ira bien
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour mon chat j'ai
fait du pain perdu dans
sara lee lee le devoir nous appelle
sortez le rôti du congélateur je le
ferai ce soir
ne sera jamais imaginé
elle a l'air d'être bien
il arrive et sa ville j'ai un rendez
vous
bonjour karl éclate toi los angeles
c'est pas grave je rappellerai plus tard
à très bientôt ça m
[Musique]
oui
d
[Musique]
faux
je ne sentais pas
[Musique]
ouais
quand
pas con
mais là
[Musique]
hélas
elle
[Musique]
la nuit